past relationships shape future
relationships
you know the difference between lust and
love oh my goodness you know the
difference I feel like if you're able to
reflect if you're able to reflect and
not carry on the patterns that you had
in your past relationship 100 you need
to be self-aware yeah 100 like Erica
Perdue said in that song bag lady she's
like Pack Light because if you bring all
your emotional baggage yeah into your
future relationships they're never going
to work no one wants to deal with your
bag is she married now or no Erica I
think she's got a kid I don't know she's
got kids
really yeah wow I didn't I didn't know
who she was though
yeah she was cool though I love her
she's she's sick do you guys think that
the best predictor of uh future
relationships is past relationships yeah
yeah yeah I don't think so because I
feel like in life like if you go into a
relationship and you learn the lesson
that it's taught you after you've broken
up
then no but if you don't learn the
lesson then the universe is just going
to keep sending you the same person in a
different body and you're going to have
to keep
we say the universe is gonna you pick up
hold on hold on I'm adding that to my
lesson wait wait wait wait I'm adding
that to my list of things like I want
girls to stop saying the universe but
you know what some people really
genuinely believe them no yeah the
universe does because if not if not why
is it that the same person with the same
character traits with the same habits
with the same comments again
I can I can break it down for you
choices
no I'm saying like you either like toxic
you probably like toxic people and
you're probably toxic at the same time
girls will take accountability off of
them and say it's that it's and I'm not
trying to pick on you but it's like
they'll say the universe and then it's
like it might not be the universe it's
probably you but at the same time though
a lot of toxic relationships don't start
off toxic they start off like normal
relationships
they change after the honeymoon phase
that's true well I would say is yeah
poor choices but it's because you
haven't learned your lesson the first
time yeah exactly and there's only so
many relationships you're going to go
through before you need to look inwards
and be like okay maybe I'm the problem
yeah and I but self-reflection is hard
you know yeah
it might not it might not start toxic
but then you probably do something
that's toxic if every relationship you
know yeah no one's perfect so actually
relating to what you said it makes sense
because when you said environment and um
how it relates I feel like it makes
sense and when you said issue
environment and you so it all depends on
where you come from your upgrade
upbringing and what makes you who you
are so I feel like when you're in
relationship a past relationship can
make your future relationship better but
how that makes it better is by you
knowing yourself
[Music]
reflection if you don't reflecting
yourself or if you don't know yourself
or if you don't you battle if you
couldn't do the same thing it's like
wherever you see or whatever that is
what you're gonna attract do any of you
guys go to the gym are you guys yeah I
guess sometimes I go so if you if you're
practicing squats you get better at
squatting right so wouldn't you say the
only way to get better at being in a
healthy relationship is to be in a
healthy relationship how would you I
would think so but also I think to be in
a healthy relationship you need to know
what your boundaries are and you need to
like respect them like going back to
boundaries again like if you have set
boundaries and you respect your own
boundaries and you have a level of
self-respect for yourself then it sets
the tone for other people to come into
your life and respect those boundaries
what kind of boundaries are helpful in a
relationship I think a level of trust
being able to give people space if they
need it okay trust you know not being
like controlling or anything and being
controlling okay yeah I mean everyone's
boundaries are kind of different it kind
of depends on the person but and I think
it also depends on that you've got to be
independent as a woman and be okay with
being on your own like you need to learn
to love yourself it's co-dependency that
really it believes it's like okay it's
cool he can leave you know what I mean
I've got a lot of girls rely a lot of
guys a lot of girls depends do you know
anyone that's been married for 30 plus
years
yeah 20 plus years not 20 20 plus years
do you feel like that's the woman's
mentality is I need a lot of boundaries
and I need to not need him
I don't think it's about not needing the
person but I think that's what there's a
fine line between like there could be
something having your own life and then
like codependence I mean like some some
like girls they make their relationship
their whole life and then they break up
with their partner and they're lost they
don't have no friends anymore because
they drop out all their friends right
because they don't know themselves they
lose their whole personality because
they've made their whole life their
relationship
I'm a couple years older than you and
usually those girls actually end up
getting into a relationship and starting
a family young so it's just like instead
of like you guys might have different
skills like you're good at singing
you're good at that those girls just
have relationship skills so they just
usually they just usually get into
another religion I mean they're
heartbroken for a bit but then they they
find another guy because she proves she
could be a good girlfriend to that one
so that she goes into another yeah some
people are just relationship people I
think they're just made to like be in a
relationship some people have the goals
of like oh they're just like young or
they're just naive and just say they
just get taken advantage of yeah there's
a very very like fine
there's a very very fine line between
that I think because yeah there's a lot
of there is a fine line just make a man
their whole life because it gives them
validation because they don't love
themselves yeah and when you don't love
yourself like I know it's cliche but
like how can you expect someone to love
you properly if you don't love and
respect yourself how would you expect
them to love you yeah you need to set
the tone for them you know if you show
them that you don't respect yourself and
you don't love yourself then how are
they going to do how are they going to
love you and respect you so how do you
show them that I just I always hear
these terms with girls and I just it's
always so broad don't give them too many
chances you know what I mean you know
like yeah yeah don't give them too many
chances do you think the 30-year
marriage 20-year marriage the the
longest marriage you know do you think
the woman's mentality was don't give him
too many chances no no I'm talking about
successful outcomes so if we look at
people with with good outcomes because
we don't agree long marriage is better
than nobody breaking up right yeah yeah
okay but I'm talking I'm talking about
like the dating like when you're dating
before you get into it because like I
said I haven't actually been in a proper
relationship so I can only go for
experience from dating so I'm gonna say
I know these guys I think some of you
have been a relationships or no no
but like I I haven't so yeah but I feel
like you have to make sure what was the
question again do you think that do you
think that the mentality of cut a guy
off quick it was good for a long-term
relationship don't give him too many no
if he's cheating then yeah you've got it
because he will most likely do it why do
we always go to like the worst case
scenario I think I think
um because of female in the beginning I
think if someone like if you express
that you don't like how someone's
treating you and then they continue to
treat you like that and then you still
take them back that's unhealthy that's
not you not respecting your boundaries
because you don't like the way you're
being treated but you're gonna stay
there because you like him or you think
that he likes you because he does nasty
things to you and then he might buy some
flowers afterwards and be like oh I'm so
sorry but then he does it again
marriage or you're in a relationship and
you have a few issues like you don't you
don't like agree on certain things those
things can easily be resolved with good
communication
yeah I mean I agree with you that you
should cut people off that aren't
married if you want to be married that
aren't marriage minded quick but I think
sometimes like as women we always jump
to like the worst case scenario it's
either cheating I only know this I've
done these shows so many times yeah we
have fantasies
to get better before I used to always
think of the worst case scenario but now
I'm like
um
I think sometimes you just gotta go with
the flow like yeah literally you do you
can't think too much into it obviously
if you're not being treated right then
obviously he's got to go yeah 100 it's
as simple as that okay
um
can a person change and no longer be
considered a toxic X yes 100 I think
they can change when they look inwards
okay
um no
you don't think people can change no
depending on how long you're trying to
get them to change
yeah depending on how long do you have
no but you know what it is a man or a
woman anyone will only change when
they're ready to change yeah force them
to change because they're never they're
never going to change for you like if
you stay with a man hoping that he will
change he's not going to change for you
it's got to be genuine as well it's got
to be a genuine change yeah like it's
got a last yeah and don't forget like
sometimes you know guys I'm sure go
through stuff as well like certain
triggers might trigger them to like step
back toxic toxic attributes to like you
know come back that aren't healthy so
that needs to be taken into a cat as
well when he makes that change that has
you completely like looked within
himself that we keep saying and like
herself well it's just interesting
whenever I say toxic acts we always say
man what about her I think it's because
we're all kind of like yeah
yeah but like a toxic girl you know
because you said you knew a lot of toxic
girls or you've seen that situation
toxic relationships and I've seen like
toxic relationships with a woman is like
the aggressor or like the the toxic
person and did she change
um I don't know her well enough to know
that so I can't really speak on it but
um
yeah people some people change but you
know what it is again like
self-reflection is really hard to do
when you have to look inwards and look
at yourself on your own flaws a lot of
people would rather ignore that because
ignorance is bliss as someone in the
chat said people only change when the
reality of their life convinces them to
make a change yeah 100 big big
situations happen or something that
would just so yeah yeah I feel like a
lot of people have to hit rock bottom
for them to realize okay I need to
change this I need to like that's true
yeah
that's true one time I was dating a guy
that my dad didn't like and
um I said I said dad do people change it
was a couple years ago
and he looks at me and he says yes
they get worse over time
it's gonna be worse than 10 years so we
should choose carefully because it's not
gonna get better
no it's true though because it will just
get under your skin more word as the
time goes on if you don't like something
you're not vocal about it from the
beginning like it's gonna how do you
expect it's gonna dwell on your mind
yeah I feel like
you can't fix a person a person can only
fix themselves and for them to fix
themselves they have to make countless
mistakes in order for them to realize yo
whoa what am I doing that's it 100 I
agree with that and that includes sorry
sorry that includes going back to the
triggers you were talking about because
without those triggers how would you
know that you're ready for change or
you're ready to change you know okay I
think a lot of people can like
um based our like toxicity of like about
upbringing and stuff but you know what
you get to a certain age where you need
to be held accountable for like your
behaviors and stuff not necessarily you
can't blame it you can't blame it on
your your childhood and stuff because at
the end of the day like you can see
someone who's got like grown up with
like alcoholic parents actually somebody
I saw a post and it was like twins and
they grew up in a household with like
two alcoholic parents and one of them
became a complete alcoholic just like
his parents and the other one fixed his
whole life had a successful business and
stuff you know like if you you've been
given cards but it's just like it
depends what you want to do like you can
either learn from that and be like okay
I don't want to be like that I'm going
to make a change so I'm not that kind of
person or you can just be like Oh I'm
like that because my parents were like
that I'm like this because I grew up in
a bad environment
you think that's because of mindset it's
mindset so why did you say it now the
reason why I said not necessarily was
because like she just said the first
twin decided to be more of an alcoholic
and the second Twin decided make a
change of his life and there are two
different people but still one person
who's doing the same household but as
you just said mindset it depends on who
you're around with yes it is a decision
but at the same time
you can't do by yourself you need people
to help you 100 don't don't you get to
choose the people in your life yeah you
do by the same time over the age of
eight you guys have all come across
really but I'm pretty sure you guys are
walking across really bad people but you
didn't end up being like them you
chilled with them yeah but you're not
them right but at the same time you like
realize like okay I don't want to be
like this so you're not going to
associate yourself with people that
again it's like having having
um boundaries is that what you accept
into your life yeah 100 you know what I
mean the same way we don't have the same
bodies the same way we don't have the
same mindset no 100 a mindset is
something that you learn like over time
yeah and everyone's way of learning is
different at the same way school isn't
for everyone it's the same way the way
you take education differently yeah yeah
so I can't get better personally change
their lives but at the same time like
you can't sit there and blame everything
else for the way your life's turned out
because everyone has a sub story like
everyone goes through yeah but it
just it's like it's about how you it's
about how you deal with it you know if
you don't want to be in that situation
then you work towards getting yourself
out of that situation you know if you
sit there and you sulk and you're like
oh I'm in this situation and you don't
make no change like how would you expect
to grow how do you expect yeah exactly
you have to become the change and take
actions towards that change like
thinking and all of that is nothing with
that action you got it
consistently execute it that's really
important
it is I have a question for you guys do
you think that people who constantly
label their exes as toxic are looking
for an excuse for the failed
relationship yes yes a hundred percent
yes yes I would say yes as well yeah
because it gets to a point again like
you need to look inwards if all of your
relationships are toxic and the other
person was always the bad person
look again
I'm just thinking now actually that
going back into whether I'm toxic I just
realized that I've never been a toxic
one
you've never you've never heard
of a person I've been on the sweet the
sweet guy do you feel like okay wait I'm
gonna hold on
where are you where are you were you
going through your ex's likes as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible